We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I have this habit of walking into any door that's unlocked. And it actually does me well here in the capital because you start poking around and going
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“百分之九十九的隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我有这样一个习惯，喜欢走进任何没锁的门。这在首都对我很有帮助，因为你开始四处探索，然后
into doors and you find the coolest things. You have to appreciate the moxie of someone who can wander around a federal building, open up a random door and announce to whoever's on the other side. Hello. Hi, I'm Andrea C. Brooke with NPR. If you didn't catch that, that's NPR Congressional correspondent Andrea C. Brooke. I'm a reporter. We're poking around, looking at secret things in the Capitol.
走进那些门，你会发现最酷的事情。你必须欣赏那些能够在联邦大楼里闲逛、推开一扇随机的门并向门后的人宣布的人的勇气。你好。嗨，我是NPR的安德里亚·C·布鲁克。如果你没听清，那是NPR国会记者安德里亚·C·布鲁克。我是一名记者。我们在四处查看，寻找国会大厦里的秘密东西。
I am so in love with Andrea C. Brooke right now. The woman on the other side of the door tells Andrea that she needs to leave and that walking into random doors in the basement of the US Capitol building is not what she's supposed to be doing. And that's 99% of visible's own Sam Greenspan. He went with Andrea to the Capitol building.
我现在太爱安德里亚·C·布鲁克了。门后的人告诉安德里亚她必须离开，并且在美国国会大厦地下室随机推门不是她应该做的事情。那是“百分之九十九的隐形”自己的萨姆·格林斯潘。他和安德里亚一起去了国会大厦。
I'm so jealous of him right now. 99% of visible's own Sam Greenspan. He went with Andrea to the Capitol building. I'm so jealous of him right now. That's not what we're supposed to be doing. That doesn't deter you though. No. Are you kidding? I don't care what they think I'm supposed to be doing. I'm here to cover the United States Capitol. And frankly, I see this as part of it.
我现在太嫉妒他了。“百分之九十九的隐形”自己的萨姆·格林斯潘。他和安德里亚一起去了国会大厦。我现在太嫉妒他了。那不是我们应该做的事。不过这并没有阻止你。不。开玩笑吧？我才不管他们觉得我应该做什么。我来这里是为了报道美国国会。坦白说，我认为这也是其中的一部分。
I think so. I think so. I think this as part of it. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so.
我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我认为这是其中的一部分。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。
I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so.
我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。
I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. I think so. overwhelming structure. you know, riding the bills and cleaning the toilets. As if we could tell the difference. Am I right? The capital is known for its grandeur. The revtanda statuary hall, the crypt, the marble staircases.
我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。我也这么认为。压倒性的结构。你知道，起草法案和清理厕所。就好像我们能分清区别一样。我说的对吗？国会大厦以其宏伟壮丽而闻名。圆形大厅、雕像大厅、地下室、大理石楼梯。
This place is unbelievably ornamental. The walls upstairs have gorgeous freezes, you know, with birds and squirrels and gorgeous, gorgeous, linting beautiful paintwork. And that's all the stuff we're supposed to see. But when you're an Embederate Dorinob Turner and Snoop like Andrea C. Brook, you also get to know the Capitol below the surface. Literally, the basement.
这个地方有着难以置信的装饰。楼上的墙壁有华丽的带状雕饰，你知道的，有鸟类和松鼠，还有华丽、华丽、光彩夺目的美丽画作。这些都是我们应该看到的东西。但当你像安德里亚·C·布鲁克那样是一个无所畏惧的门廊探索者和侦探时，你也能了解地表之下的国会大厦。字面意思上的地下室。
Down here, there's a whole bunch of engineers, you know, like HVAC engineers in blue uniforms that say, like, you know, Joe, on a... The purpose of the building, the business of government trickles down to these lower levels. The members of the House, Republican caucus, and sometimes the Democrats meet in the basement for their sort of closed door secret strategy sessions.
在这里，有一大群工程师，你知道的，比如穿着蓝色制服的暖通空调工程师，上面写着，比如说，乔……建筑物的目的，政府的事务一直渗透到这些较低的层级。众议院成员、共和党核心会议，有时还有民主党人，会在地下室举行某种闭门的秘密战略会议。
And it's a really good place to place to get kind of a tip from members that you know about what's going on. But the main reason we're here is to see a little bit of the architectural grandeur that is trickled down here too. Oh it says please check in with the engineers which I think they'll do just you know One thing that's cool is I'll just show to you Andrea is leading you through the serpentine route of alleys and doorways and really in the uh what oh my gosh Here we are I know it's amazing and then there are these bathtubs It's amazing, they're these beautiful marble bathtubs with marble steps that lead up to
这是一个从你认识的议员那里打探正在发生的事情的好地方。但我们来这里的主要原因是为了看看这里也流传下来的建筑宏伟。哦，上面写着请与工程师核实，我想他们会做的，你知道的。酷的一点是，我会向你展示的，安德里亚正引领你穿过小巷和门口的蜿蜒路线，实际上在呃，哦天哪。我们到了。我知道这很神奇，然后这里有这些浴缸。太神奇了，它们是漂亮的大理石浴缸，有大理石台阶通往
them in brass fittings and they're deep, beautiful bathtubs. Just to describe it a little bit, it's sort of a white ivory marble that has this luster. It reminds me of the Venus de Milo or something. It shines, it glows a little bit, and it's got very faint black veins in it, and it's just gorgeous. The curves in it are so gentle and continuous. But for all the grandeur that Tubbs possessed,
它们和黄铜配件，它们很深，很漂亮。简单描述一下，它是一种带有这种光泽的乳白色大理石。让我想起了米洛斯的维纳斯之类雕像。它闪闪发光，散发着微光，上面有非常微弱的黑色纹理，简直太华丽了。里面的曲线是如此柔和连贯。但尽管这些浴缸拥有如此宏伟的气势，
the room itself is the exact opposite. This place was supposed to cool off senators, now it cools and heats the entire capital building. There's a big HVAC equipment and computer servers and large steel cabinets containing god knows what. Even though the bathtubs along with the sink and toilet were here first, they're the ones that came out of place. The bathtubs were installed around 1860 during the expansion of the capital.
房间本身却恰恰相反。这个地方原本是用来给参议员降温的，现在它为整个国会大厦提供制冷和供暖。这里有大型的暖通空调设备、计算机服务器和装有天知道什么的大型钢制柜子。尽管浴缸以及水槽和马桶是最先来到这里的，但它们却是与这里格格不入的东西。这些浴缸大约在1860年国会大厦扩建期间安装。
DC is known for its swampy summers, and legend has it that senators could be banished from the chamber if they were too smelly. It still wreaks, but yeah, back then, it was less figurative. And most people at the time, even politicians, they didn't have indoor plumbing at home. So Congress needed a place where the politicians
华盛顿特区以其闷热的夏天而闻名，传说如果参议员们身上有异味，就会被赶出会场。这里现在还是很难闻，不过，嗯，在那个时候，这就不是比喻了。而且当时大多数人，甚至是政客，家里都没有室内管道设施。所以国会需要一个地方让政客们
could go and wash up. Andrea reads from an informational card beside the tub. Okay, here we go. Each bathtub, and I am standing in one right now, was carved in Italy from a single block of carara marble. Three bathtubs were shipped from Genoa, Italy in July 1859 and reached Baltimore in November
可以去清洗。安德里亚朗读浴缸旁边的信息卡。好了，我们开始。每个浴缸，我此刻正站在其中一个里面，都是在意大利由一整块卡拉拉大理石雕刻而成的。三个浴缸于1859年7月从意大利热那亚装船运出，并于11月抵达巴尔的摩
of that year. July to November. The other three were shipped from Leigh Horn, Italy in September of 1859 and arrived in New York in January of 1860. The precise dates of the bathtubs arrival and installation at the capital are uncertain, but the Senate bathing room is known to have been in operation as of February 23rd, 1860. Each of the six tubs cost 90 bucks in 1860, which is around $2,500 a piece today. And that was just to buy the tubs. You got to figure it was still more to ship them from Italy, receive them at the port of Baltimore, transport them to Capitol Hill, and then you had a build of bathing facilities suitable to a senator.
那一年。7月到11月。另外三个于1859年9月从意大利里窝那装船，并于1860年1月抵达纽约。浴缸到达和安装在国会大厦的确切日期尚不确定，但众所周知，参议院浴室自1860年2月23日起就开始运营了。1860年，这六个浴缸每个售价90美元，按今天的价值计算，大约每个2500美元。这还只是买浴缸的钱。你还得考虑到，把它们从意大利运出来、在巴尔的摩港接收、运输到国会山，还要建造适合参议员的洗浴设施，这些都需要花更多的钱。
They had Oakwood paneling, plaster cornices, mint and tile, egg and dart molding, of the six original tubs only two are left, and one has a piece of plywood over it that props up some padlocked steel mystery box. The other was decommissioned years ago. This place is a total collusion of ares, not just old versus new. And I know that just a little bit ago, we were considering the capital building as just a building.
它们有橡木镶板、石膏檐口、明顿瓷砖、蛋镖饰线条，原本的六个浴缸只剩下两个，其中一个上面盖着一块胶合板，上面支撑着某种带挂锁的钢制神秘箱子。另一个多年前就已经退役了。这个地方简直是各种时代的碰撞，不仅仅是新旧对比。我知道就在不久前，我们还认为国会大厦只是一座建筑物。
It's impossible to look at this room and not see a metaphorical debate right here in the basement. We are having this great debate in our country, whether you're in the Tea Party or the Occupy movement both share the same concern about who the government is for. And I think the politicians have tried really hard to make it look as if the government is for the people and not for the gorgeously-appointed bathers of the world. For example, a new king rich took over the House speakership in 1995 after a giant sweep of the 94 elections.
看着这个房间，不可能不在地下室这里看到一场隐喻性的辩论。我们国家正在进行一场巨大的辩论，无论你是茶党还是占领运动，双方都对政府究竟为谁服务有着同样的担忧。我认为政客们非常努力地让人觉得政府是为人民服务的，而不是为世界上那些拥有华丽装饰的洗浴者服务的。例如，在94年选举大获全胜后，金·里奇于1995年接任众议院议长职务。
He found that there were buckets of ice still being delivered to every single member of Congress's office, even though they all had refrigerators with ice makers. It was back from the time when you had to buy ice separately, and so they sort of shut down all that stuff. At the same time, they got rid of the house history, and they defunded all of these things they thought of as luxuries and they got rid of a lot of the funding for saving things like this. As Andrea puts it, the spending versus austerity question is really just the modern form of the quintessential American question of government.
他发现仍然有冰块被送到每一个国会议员的办公室，尽管他们都有带制冰机的冰箱。这是过去你不得不单独买冰的时候留下的，所以他们基本上关闭了所有这些东西。与此同时，他们取消了众议院的历史记录，并取消了所有这些他们认为是奢侈品的东西的资金支持，他们取消了许多用于保存像这样东西的资金。正如安德里亚所说，支出与紧缩的问题实际上只是美国经典的政府问题的现代形式。
Which is how much government should exist? What is it there to do? And at one point, about 140 some odd years ago, there was this idea of the government being an important institution, one that would have gorgeously appointed baths. And now we're sitting in a boiler room and the beautiful minton tile
那就是应该存在多少政府？它的职责是什么？大约140多年前，人们曾一度认为政府是一个重要的机构，一个会拥有华丽装饰浴室的机构。现在我们坐在一个锅炉房里，美丽的明顿瓷砖
has been painted over with industrial gray paint and the walls are kind of dirty and it's loud and and there's no way to pay homage to it anymore. It's tucked in a corner and dirty and there's a roach trap on the floor. We can have gorgeous, you have a marble kind of sparkles a little bit if it's a little bit clean look closer. You see this luster? I don't think there's any modern political persuasion that would advocate for the installation of luxurious $3,000 marble bathtubs for senators as lovely as they may be. The bathtubs, not the senators.
被刷上了工业灰漆，墙壁有点脏，而且很吵，没有办法再向它致敬了。它被藏在一个角落里，很脏，地板上还有一个蟑螂夹。我们可以拥有华丽的，如果你把它稍微弄干净一点，大理石会闪闪发光，仔细看看。你看到这种光泽了吗？我不认为有任何现代政治派别会主张为参议员安装价值3000美元的豪华大理石浴缸，无论它们多么可爱。我说的是浴缸，不是参议员。
But if the Ornate marble bathtubs are already there, they were installed 150 years ago. What do you do with them? What represents the people now? I mean, it's interesting that it's still preserved, but it's likely not going to be restored. No. Not unless we had some resurgence and respect for our government, and you imagine the people wanting to pay, even if it was only, I don't know,
但如果华丽的大理石浴缸已经在那里了，它们是150年前安装的。你该拿它们怎么办？现在是什么代表人民？我的意思是，有趣的是它仍然被保留着，但它可能不会被恢复。不。除非我们对政府重新产生某种复兴和尊重，否则你很难想象人们愿意掏钱，哪怕只有，我不知道，
just give it $500,000 just to be crazy. Just to restore this area, it may be a lot more than that actually, come to think of how much you'd have to move. But, I don't know. Yeah. You want to go open some doors? Yes.
哪怕只是拿出50万美元来发疯。仅仅是为了修复这个区域，仔细想想，要搬迁的东西那么多，实际花费可能会更多。但是，我不知道。是的。你想去开几扇门吗？是的。
99% invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan, who I'm so jealous of and he's totally fired. I'm so jealous of and he's totally fired. I'm in my house. He's traipsing around the capital building with Andrea Sibruck. You're dead to me. In Mirrogan Mars, with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, 91.7, local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco.
本周的“百分之九十九的隐形”由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，我太嫉妒他了，他完全被解雇了。我太嫉妒他了，他完全被解雇了。我在家里。他正和安德里亚·西布拉克一起在国会大厦闲逛。你在我这儿已经是个死人了。联合罗曼·马尔斯，并得到Lunar的支持，用创意创造不同。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。
We are distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public at prx.org. You can find the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, or you can just catch up with us on the website, 99%invisible.org you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们由 PRX 发行，这是一个公共广播交流平台，致力于让公共广播更加公开，网址是 prx.org。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目。我在 Twitter 上是 @RomanMars，或者你也可以在我们的网站 99%invisible.org 上关注我们。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。